my name is Bradley wojtek i'm a PhD
neuro scientist I work at currently the
University of California at San
Francisco I just finished up my PhD in
neuroscience at UC Berkeley last year
and i'm here because i have also become
a zombie neuroscience expert apparently
so this was kind of a thing I did with a
colleague of mine timber Stein and who's
a researcher out at Pittsburgh now and
he and I for fun on the side we tried to
figure out what his ami brain would look
like and then from there we said okay
well given what the zombie brain that
looks like as we think it should look
based upon these zombie behaviors that
were observing what would that tell us
in terms of surviving a zombie outbreak
right and so we came up a couple of
things first of all we decided that
based on the pattern of brain damage
that the zombies have to have they're
very susceptible to distraction for
example so we recommend that people
would distract the zombies to get away
their memories would also have to be
very poor and so you could maybe hide
for a little while and they might forget
about you and walk away and also they're
traditionally very slow right so you
could just outrun them or something so
yeah we came up with this whole pattern
of behaviors that they would have to
have so I mean to be upfront about this
right this all started is kind of like a
grad school art right like we would sit
around and watch a zombie movies and you
know for a couple of years we talk about
what would zombie brains have to look
like right and it's it's really
surprisingly taken off from there about
how people how interested people are
suddenly in this the zombie genre itself
has exploded in the last five to ten
years right but in terms of what we've
said about the zombie brain that all
comes from observing the behaviors of
zombies right so we watched a lot of
movies and we tried to piece out these
different aspects of zombie behaviors
and so you've got you've got the
inability to speak and the slow
movements or uncoordinated movements
loss of memory the habits like in a lot
of the Romero movies especially dawn of
the dead
right they return to like the shopping
malls and you know for Romero is a
comment on consumerism but we use that
as a stepping point of saying well
people these zombies still have these
old behaviors these old habits built in
right and so from a neuroscientific
perspective we could actually talk about
what does that mean in terms of the
brain all right so I mean that this is
all this all came about from these kinds
of discussions